hello i'm mike bishop from the
university of california san francisco
i'm going to tell you the story of how i
became a scientist
and where that led me it's a rather
improbable story
which has a few lessons in it about
becoming a scientist
and the and the process of science
i grew up i spent my childhood in a
town of 400 in rural pennsylvania my
father was a
lutheran pastor with two very small
parishes
my family valued academic achievement
but science was not a presence
i cannot remember even in the remotest
of my extended family someone involved
in science and it was never
a topic of conversation in the household
my first eight years of schooling were
in a two-room schoolhouse
with one teacher handling grades one
through four and this another teacher
handling grades five through
eight the second teacher was a
remarkable individual
who awakened my intellect but again
there was nothing said of science other
than the collection of wildflowers
my high school was also small perhaps 80
in the class and maybe five of us
went to college the culture was
dominated by athletics
no surprise there and pubertal hormones
but still the faculty again recognized
my
academic interests and encouraged me
when i graduated
i remember thanking my track coach for
the varsity letter that i had finally
earned in my senior year
and which i actually still have at home
and he responded by saying that
he thought it was more important that i
had been valedictorian of the class
and he would rather be thanked for the
physics course he had taught me
which come to think of it was not that
bad
i went off to a small liberal arts
college gettysburg college
on the famous civil war battlefield
and that was a glorious time for me
the faculty were devoted and accessible
i dabbled widely in the liberal arts
i took enough science but not a lot
and i gave no thought to being a
scientist
while i was in high school a family
physician took me under his wing
and began to encourage me towards a
career in medicine
so i took the requisite pre-medical
courses but
still was not certain about my vocation
to dramatize how naive i was
during my junior year uh one of my
most favored professors called me in and
asked me
what i wanted to do he wanted to counsel
me
about where to go next and i told him
that
i was going to go to medical school
but that i was interested in an academic
career
and his response was well then you
should consider going to harvard
and my response was where's that i had
literally never heard of the place
in due course i went off to harvard and
harvard was a revelation
first of all it was in boston where i
could
sate my burgeoning appetite for the fine
arts
and secondly for the first time research
permeated the educational environment
it was spoken of repeatedly by our
faculty and more importantly
among my peers in my class were
individuals who had had sophisticated
research experience as an undergraduate
and had a profound influence on my
aspirations
by the end of my second year medical
school i was at a loss as to what i was
going to do
it was becoming clear to me that i did
not want to practice medicine
i had never experienced research what to
do
my instructor in pathology rescued me by
offering me a fellowship
in the pathology department at the
massachusetts general hospital
where i would both study and do clinical
pathology
and tinker in his lab i took it
who well who would decline a
paid year off from medical school free
to do almost anything i wanted
the autonomy of that year was
extraordinary
i worked hard but i also had the
opportunity to start
teaching myself what i might have to
know to become a scientist
and from that reading
i became enamored of the newly emerging
field known as molecular
biology when i returned to medical
school
i began to look for a way into that
field i realized that i was not
sophisticated enough
to go to the heart of the matter i would
have to find
some outer niche of the field for
a beginner like myself and i was
assisted in that
by an elective course that i took
the teacher in that course was a man
named elmer fefercorn
who had a tiny laboratory and he took me
in
to begin my first research experience
during my free time
as a third year medical student i had
decided to work on
animal viruses i had decided to work on
animal viruses because
they were simple they provided an
accessible way to understand
the cell but they were still
understudied
in particular they had not received much
attention from molecular biologists
i had a wonderful time during that third
year and decided i just wanted to do
research in my fourth year
so i went to the dean of
the the associate dean of students and
told him
that i would like to substitute research
in the laboratory for my fourth year
curriculum
he took a deep breath told me that that
might be professional suicide
but then agreed as long as i would take
a two-month clerkship
in what i might want to do my internship
in residency
i did that two months at the
massachusetts general hospital
in internal medicine and spent the other
10 months doing research
in a laboratory it wasn't professional
suicide
i got an internship in a residency at
the massachusetts general hospital
which was a magnificent experience and
then i went off to the national
institutes of health
to finally get some serious research
training
there i began to work on polio virus
with the same rationale as before here
was a
simple organism that utilized the
mammalian cell for its replication
and by studying that replication we
could learn things about the cell
itself as well as about the virus i
published my first papers
and became friends with a scientist from
germany
who invited me to come to hamburg for a
year my wife and i went off for our
first experience living abroad
and nothing worked in the laboratory but
while i was in germany
i fell in love with romanesque
architecture german expressionism and i
would say in retrospect
the year was an immense success while i
was there
i received some job offers i never did a
job
search those were different times
i had two offers from prestigious
institutions on the east coast
and one from a place called the
university of california san francisco
in san francisco i literally had never
heard of that place
but my mentor at the national institutes
of health had moved there
and was trying to recruit me there so i
visited
i immediately fell in love with the city
and i saw a huge opportunity because at
the time
university of california san francisco
widely known as ucsf
was not much more than a trade school
but it was aspiring to become a
first-rate research institution
so i was offered glorious laboratory
space
and the freedom to do as i as i wished
when i arrived at ucsf i met
warren levinson who had set up a
laboratory to study rao sarcoma virus
a tumor virus a virus that caused
sarcomas in chickens
and could be studied in cell culture in
vitro
as well at the time
the replication of this virus was a
complete mystery
mystery was quickly solved by the
discovery of reverse transcriptase
two years after i arrived in san
francisco
uh i was joined by harold varmus as a
who worked who came as a postdoctoral
fellow we
formed a research alliance that lasted
for 15 years
and a friendship that endures to this
day within four years of forming our
alliance
we had found a way to pry open the black
box of the cancer cell
we had discovered that the tumor-causing
gene
of rao sarcoma virus was derived from
the normal cell
in due course it became apparent that
there were many such genes in the normal
cell
that could be could give rise to cancer
genes
if changed in some way this discovery
launched harold and me on richly
rewarding research careers
that both of us have written about in
books that you can find on amazon.com
when i reflect on my career four things
strike me
first of all it's important to chart
your own course
that will guarantee your passion for
your avocation
second choose to do something important
the principal mark of a great scientist
is the ability to recognize an important
problem
before others have seen it
third try to do something new
try to help start a new line of research
it carries the highest risk but also the
highest reward
and fourth believe in your ideas
believe in your ideas and pursue them
until they've
uh they're either proven or discredited
because above all else science is an
adventure in
ideas thank you very much for listening